you can go ahead and step out for me
yeah you can step
out my well now I'm going to tell you to
step out of the vehicle it's not an
option anymore
okay the original was you can bring your
phone with
you Dar Daria listen to me step out of
the vehicle and I'm going to talk to you
over by my car okay if you don't step
out I'm going to pull you out
okay
are
yes asked you step out of the vehicle
Daria okay steing out I've asked but I
asked you I I'm telling you now step out
of the vehicle step out
or we can discuss that later hard hey
you guys aren't giving me the space to
all right
and nice to meet youall and you get out
of the
car I'm going to push you out here about
3 seconds you reach for that one more
time I'm going to yoke your ass out sir
get out of the car I'm going to move you
out the
car am I being yes what stop fucking
reaching wait why are you touching me
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you guys doing wait
wait did I do something wrong yes why I
told you to step out multiple times you
wouldn't step out stop s
got hey give me your other hand okay
wellit this is bad hold on got that arm
hold on this is not right
wait stop
kicking hold
on guys you got no but I don't
need
hey so there's cameras on my car okay we
have cameras
don't have sorry I get over to be
miserable just my car
insurance I'll show you my car insurance
is that I don't need that
now so wait a minute what am I getting
put your leg down I didn't get sober to
be miserable or to be well the thing is
I don't think you're sober right
now all right go ahead and walk her to
my car real quick
you got it yeah and this is for no shoes
Oro want see my car no I no longer want
to see your car so what do you want to
do I want you to stand right
here spread your feet wait you run in my
car and Sho
spread do you have anything on you miss
and I'm also and I'm also in the Laing
citizen of America okay correct yeah we
yeah we got our
hand
mirle highspeed chases TI we got a
unruly suspects I will kill that mother
T me no do it stay in the Box I like it
K dramatic DUI I'm a pass TR to do and
shocking body cam footage hey get on the
ground get on the ground law on crime
presents body cam the place for real raw
and wild police videos you should have
seen it was good it's on body camera
I'll show it to you catch the action and
subscribe to our new YouTube channel
[Music]
now I didn't get here and I don't know
why my braake light sit in my car okay
thanks for telling me about my brake
light okay is that's why you pulled me
over yes sit in my
car Freedom um am I being detained am I
being arrested not yet put your feet in
the car I'm not getting in the car if
I'm not being arrested Miss P I don't do
anything sit down am I being arrested
sit down for what sorry for what wait
for what Miss P sit down Miss P you am I
being
arrested yes you
are wait what's going
on
goly all right Daria do you want to try
your Miranda Rights one more time how
about I stand up face to face with you
okay well let me let me respectful human
being Daria let me read you through your
rights real quick and then I'm going to
let you get out of the car okay no Daria
hold on let me put my posture up my here
do you want your shoes my posture you
want your shoes this gles I don't have
your glasses um on according to 6 o00
okay what what time is it okay Daria I'm
giving you your shoes if you say it's
5:00 okay step out for me it's 5 now so
my glasses were taken away away from me
okay and then you're saying Daria put
your shoes on and then you put them on
top of the car Daria put your shoes on
at 5 something and step out for me I'm
just saying like what is the obstru
where's the obstruction coming from
because you didn't get out of the car
now put your shoes on because you took
my do you want me to yank you out of the
car again
absolutely do you want your shoes or
not the
living I like my glasses because I can't
see so who where was the obstruction
coming I already told you I'm not put
your shoe on. put your shoe on the
glasses are on top of my okay for that I
want my glasses walk to that door wait
we're not going to do this again no
that's not fair you know we mirand Sor
I've already offered to read you your
Miranda multiple
times I'm going grab her
stuff
wait
put your hand right
there your right there on the car all
right on the car yep on the car all
right Dar so I'm going to walk you
through some instructions okay and we're
going to do some field sobriety tasks
all
right okay the first one go ahead and
face
me okay you push your hair out of your
eyes are you wearing any contacts right
now no and you normally wear
glasses do I normally wear glasses yes
ma'am do you normally mean I can I can
see without them okay and and where wear
my glasses on my car at 5:00 p.m. just
want it's not 5 p.m Daria let me go
through the instructions for this okay I
love my glasses I can see without them I
I miss my glasses where are my glasses
okay are you willing to do these tests
for me question it does not I'm asking
you if you're willing to do these tests
for
me you're I've got to okay so I've got
to walk through glasses I normally wear
glasses my glasses are are a treasure of
mine I like you know with that being
said I'm I'm able to see without glasses
okay and you're the one that I believe
took my glasses started yes they're
turned in here okay so
yes can I I walk through the
instructions for the first task are you
ready for are we like going out camping
stuff no we're just I'm going to walk
you through some instructions okay you
see the tip of this pin Daria do I see
what can you see the tip of this pin can
yes okay so I would hope so I hope
yeah okay so what I want you to do is
keep your feet together arms all the way
down at your sides okay I'm going to
move this pen I want you to follow the
tip of this pin with your eyes only
don't move your head okay do you want
understand those
instructions repeat it please okay so I
want you to stand with your feet
together and your arms down at your
sides when I move this pen I want you to
follow it with your eyes only I don't
want you to move your head okay does
that make sense do you understand those
instructions I appreciate you were
repeating them twice say yes I
understand you understand them I believe
I do I don't but now may I step back
nope I got to I got to be a certain
distance from you okay are you ready to
start
and I need yeah repeat them one more
time okay you're going to keep your feet
together and your arms down at your
sides feet together arms down at my
sides yep just not just just down at
your sides just loose down at your sides
okay when I move this pin I want you to
follow the pin with your eyes only do
not move your head okay do you
understand okay Eyes Only eyes only do
not meet my head correct do not move my
head correct
do you understand are you ready to
start all right D yep Eyes Only don't
move your head okay the law I've never
done this before okay well that's I'm
that's why I'm trying to re explain it
to make sure you understand okay offic
okay Eyes Only don't move your head
okay you're still moving your head yeah
yep you're moving your can I move my
eyes up and down or just I want you to I
want you to follow the pen with your
eyes only okay make sure to hold your
head still looking straight forward okay
so hold your head up look straight
forward follow the pen with your eyes
only
okay okay you ready to move on to the
next test did I do well it's it's not a
pass or fail okay are you ready to move
on to the next
test I me only you're ready to give me
the next I am okay all right so do you
see this line right here Daria um I
don't see my shoes the shoes are off or
on you're you can leave your shoes off
they've already turned them in wait
Sergeant p is that the full name it's
Deputy P yes ma' Deputy Sergeant P I
thought it's I'm not a sergeant so okay
Officer are you ready for the next test
Aria
um I'm going to give you some
instructions okay hey and I'm just
trying to I'm I'm trying to answer that
your instructions I understand I haven't
given to the I haven't given them to you
yet okay do you see this line on the
ground AR
you you see this this line right
here
yes okay so what I want you to do is
place your left foot on the line like
this you know
um all right NOP face this way thank you
for taking me thanks
for about face face towards me put your
left foot on the
line put your right foot right in front
of it with your heel touching your
toe and I it's funny that you ask I just
may I ask you a question without it as
being odd Dar are you ready to start
this task is okay let's get may I ask
you a question without the odd what's
your
question why ask me about if I need
glasses and glasses cuz that's part of
what I have to ask you for that task
give to Let's I just have to ask you
that question before I start the to see
you want me to show you my best ability
okay well this task doesn't involve your
eyes okay this is going to be a walking
test it's called the walkin turn Okay so
put your left foot on the line for me
put your right foot directly in front of
it with your heel touching your toes and
keep your arms down to your side okay I
want you to maintain this position the
whole time I'm giving you instructions
okay so for this glasses I try to
maintain okay for this task you're going
to start in this position what I want
you to do is take nine heel to to heel
to to steps down you're going to take a
Ser not yet wait Dario wait to start
until I tell you okay once you get to
the end you're going to take a series of
small steps turn around nine heeled toe
steps back okay can you get back on the
line for me Dar remember I told you to
maintain that position while I did the
whole
instructions he remember when I told you
asked you why ask me to all right we're
going to get back to this body cam in a
second but I want to take a minute to
talk about something else else that
happens all the time workplace injuries
if you get hurt at your job whether it's
a slip and fall a mechanical failure
negligence of your co-workers something
hits you you're going to need a trusted
law firm in your corner enter Pon Le
hockey Giordano a firm that is a
heavyweight in the industry that wins
all different kinds of injury cases yes
workplace but also accidents Social
Security Disability injuries they have a
track record of recovering over $1
billion for their clients and they have
won over a 100,000 cases they have 250
years of combined experience how amazing
is that so you can check out ponle
hockey geordano at ponle hockey.com
LC bodycam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833 669 4043 all right
let's get back to the body cam Dar if if
you don't listen to the instructions I'm
going to put it down as a refusal okay
why you haven't given me my shoes
okay they're already they're already
turned into your jail property okay I'm
not from here I don't know okay are you
arresting officer what am I being
arrested for I've already explained
where am I are you Dar need a law Daria
are you going to complete
this take going to get a haircut for my
interview Daria to my school are you
going to complete this task for me or
not it's a yes or no and and Sergeant
where where are your where are you with
me I'm asking you to complete a task for
me are you going to complete
it
yeah okay like I said put one foot on
the
line other foot right in front of it
Heel To
Toe nope facing
me put your other foot directly in front
of that foot with your heel touching
your toe I've never done this before
okay keep your arms down at your side
and I'm I'm going to demonstrate okay so
like I said you're going to start off
Heel To Toe keep your arms down at your
side you're going to take nine Heel To
Toe steps down take a series of small
turns nine Heel To Toe steps back you're
going to count out loud like this I'm
going to show you okay you're going to
go 1 2 3 all the way up to 9 you're
going to keep one foot on the line take
a series of small steps to turn
around one two three all the way to nine
do you understand the instructions Daria
the turnar around looks like the
turnaround so once you get all the way
up to 9 you'll take a series of small
steps and then you'll begin in one two
three yes ma'am your shoes are already
turned into the jail property okay you
do the the up and the down okay Daria do
you understand the
instructions so you asked
me you're you said you want the my
glasses okay I'm done with the glasses
conversation and of course I can do this
I would love to get on and go home
you you can begin whenever you're
ready Daria you can begin the task
whenever you're
ready
for
all right I've got one more task for you
are you ready for the
instructions do you want to do the last
test for me after the instructions are
um to be um given mhm my action here
okay do I have go home no why are we
doing this for fun
it's not for fun I told you it's to
determine if you were under the
influence while you were driving
okay because based on your driving
patterns and your actions I believe that
you were haven't been sober for over a
years okay well this is your chance to
show me that you're
sober Daria these tasks are your way to
show me that you're sober
okay are you willing to do the last task
for me peeve taking my glasses taking my
shoes of course I'm willing to do tests
I I'm not a troublemaker I don't I'm not
under the influence are you ready for me
to give you instructions however I do
respect however however all this being
said I said look I think we're here
today for a reason mhm okay darus so
what I want you to do stand with your
feet together and your hands down at
your
side darus stand with your feet together
and your hands down at your side okay
maintain that position while I give you
all the instructions okay so the next
test it's going to be the one leg stand
okay so what you're going to do is
you're going to lift one foot whichever
foot you want it's your choice you're
going to hold it about 6 Ines above the
ground with your with the bottom of your
foot flat to the ground or um parallel
with the ground I apologize and you're
going to count up to 30 are you going I
I apologize Dar let me let me restart
these instructions for you okay I
misspoke are you apologizing for can you
stand with your feet together exactly
are you apologizing for because I would
I would appreciate I'm I'm telling you I
miss spoke on the instructions so I'd
like to restart them to you okay so go
ahead and stand with your feet together
and your hands down at your side your
next task the one L stand what for the
goal of being Dar are you for the goal
of you're apologizing for the goal of
what Daria are you going to perform this
task for me yes or no if I can go home
because I'm do not think I'm a law-
abing citizen I'm asking you to perform
this task for me it's your decision if
you want to say yes if you don't say no
I'm yes okay stand with your feet
together and your arms down at your side
why if I say no what do I do do I this
is how I give you the instructions okay
so the next test the one leg stand what
you're going to do is you're going to
pick up one foot whichever foot you want
you're going to hold it about 6 in above
the ground with your foot parallel to
the floor and you're going to count
until I tell you to say stop it's going
to look like this okay it's going to be
1,1 1,2 13 1004 up until I tell you to
stop okay the whole time you're counting
I want you to look at the foot that you
have picked up do you understand all
those
instructions
Daria do you understand the instructions
for this last
task the foot the pink flot
Ando Daria this is the last chance are
you going to I understand I'm asking you
this is the last time I'm going to ask
you are you going to perform this task
or
not the the one footer the one what the
one leg stand the oneel leg stand one
leg
stand um are you going to perform this
task or not this is the last time I'm
gonna ask you
okay if this helps and this is going to
help me for what yeah you're telling me
you're sober this is your way to show me
that you're sober
okay actually you can just look at all
the meeting okay I'm going to put down
that you refuse this last task do this
I'm just saying why don't you look at
the meetings I had had it's now or never
okay we either need to start the task or
we need to move
on would you like me to go through the
instructions one more
time okay you can put your foot down
while I go through the instructions okay
keep your arms down at your side and
maintain that position while I go
through the instructions okay yes
Sergeant yes officer okay yes we're here
are you ready for the instructions are
you when I tell you to begin you're
going to pick up whichever foot you want
you're going to hold it about 6 in above
the ground with the bottom of your foot
parallel to the
floor going to maintain to the floor yes
you're going to maintain that position
and you're going to look at your foot
while counting 1001 1,2 1003 so on until
I tell you to stop okay I'm going to
demonstrate what if like somebody was
like overweight Etc like you know people
are disabled people have disabilities do
you have a disability that's going to
prent you to do this task
imagine go look at the cameras and see
all the a meetings I go to do you have a
disability or anything that's going to
prevent you from doing this task I was
up to we're going to move on my hair
cutting school on Tuesday at forid we're
going to move on to our next test okay
no I'm saying of course I'm going to do
the task but I've told you I've told you
and I don't want to tell you I'm saying
like what was I doing going sorry put
your hands behind your back for me real
quick I've got to Cuff you to walk you
back inside let me do the thing may I do
it's no we're too late for that I didn't
refuse it okay okay we're just we have
to move on I'll put the foot on fo no
Daria I have to Cuff you to walk you
back inside okay say like I just wanted
to show you that I don't know if I can
do it prop I have a disability you know
what's your what's your disability um
it's the
uh no I'm just saying I don't have a
disability okay I don't have a
disability I'm saying like people
are step forward for me can I try this
again
please what is going on we're moving on
to the next thing okay we're moving on I
apologize for not doing all let's go
inside all right it we're going to move
on to the next thing
okay that's your that's your prerogative
have a
seat so at what point have a seat I
think I need have a seat we we'll talk
about all that in a minute Daria sit
down for me just I just want to be
treated well you know I'm a good girl no
woman do hurt you sit down for me I
don't I don't want you to fall over sit
down you help you you want help you sit
down not right now goad sit down for me
right there I don't know what's going on
sit down they're going to tell you if
you sit down sit
down sit
down I'm trying to help you sit down you
said you want to
help Dar Daria can you please sit down
can you please sit um maybe my hands are
being my hands you s you know no we're
going to keep him behind your back okay
can you sit down
please
please please yall want to handle
her thank you so much thank you thank
you hey hey Daria I'm GNA ask two things
okay um I'm going to read uh a piece of
paper to you
okay all
right
hey Daria I'm going have I can't I don't
have I need my Daria Daria I'm now
requesting submit to a waffle test of
your breath for the purpose of
determining it alcohol content it called
again will you take the
test alcohol content yes yes you will
yes
okay thank you you're welcome thank you
very well hey I didn't get sober to be
come in this place and not I hear you
you know stay here you know
I did not get sober to to do such
thing how old are you
[Music]
Darian I need your badge and your
credentials like I've never been I'm
not hey
yeah you need I need to speak to my why
don't you guys call my boyfriend or
something you know he's maybe more
informative of how how this area works
at some point the jail staff will let
you get his phone number
okay not going to
ja probably
like I weigh about roughly 160 lbs
LS now remember
here um it's SP 10 minutes
hey Daria do you do you know your
address can you tell me your address
please
um so I can go home and stuff like go
you're taking me back to my address or
do you want me to call Uber or no I I
just need to write down your address so
I know where you
live the one on my license is
well I I don't need the one on your
license I need to know where you
live if you live somewhere different
than your license you can tell me a
different address that's okay just
wherever you stay wherever you sleep
every
night
uh you said it's on not with him no no
I'm homeless you're homeless yeah
because no no no I'm saying like I was
I'm in the process of moving okay I mean
look look are you currently staying with
your boyfriend is that the issue and
your boyfriend lives on CU I want to get
I was getting my haircut to go to school
okay cuz I can't really you
know hey Dar whose house is on is it
your house or is it your boyfriend's
house
um
M you just told me you
live just my belongings are there that's
all who lives there with
you so I'm living I was living with uh
my boyfriend yeah the boyfriend the one
that I'm trying to love and just give
him all the you know okay what's his
name or
not what's what's your boyfriend's name
d
um I'd rather leave my sponsor my
sponsor I I'm just asking so that I can
write down a correct address where all
of your things are at and if I can look
him up I can maybe get the correct
numbers that are on the house um let's
see okay and I can think about that it's
yeah you you don't know his name I said
remember
do you not want to talk to me
anymore
um I'm just try to give you um if I
should give you my sponsor um Michelle
uh I just thinking which sponsor number
because I can live with them they're
more trusted
trusted Source they're The Trusted
Source can I ask you can I ask you
another question or do you want my
parents or what no I just I have another
question for you who
is that's your
boyfriend's okay does he know that you
have his debit
card
get so he gave you the debit card to get
a
haircut my boyfriend I'm just asking cuz
I've got to I've got to get this back to
him I don't want to talk
okay all right come on D it's like he
didn't know and in the car all
this